alors qu'est ce qu'on fait là où là j'ai
plein de dossiers et vous savez je te
remets bientôt culte university
attendait puisque je me remets bien que
baba alors cette séquence
enfin un peu de gel c'est cacher le gel
[Rires]
oui c'est sa coque secondes et ça c'est
50 secondes ça toi c'est parti comme ça
c'est bien tous et bienvenue dans sa
course folle inside du pmp et on
commence tout de suite avec un baba très
agitée ça va en tout cas entre notre ami
benjamin castaldi et kelly c'est
toujours l'amour fou je t'emmerde
écriture sans marien on dirait une
touffe de 2,2 du macumba
[Musique]
ça sent la 22e ou à bisons la romaine
puis encore une fois baba d analyse très
pertinente chaud et magnéto de l'autre
côté mace matin et 143 vous connaissiez
nicolas pernikoff aussi nicolas pernice
boube regard d'un fonds par nos
je vais voir mis le cul je suis sure you
forget d'or cette semaine par thomas
s'est pris un vent mais s'est pris un
ouragan dans la gueule
[Musique]
et franchement il ya à nadir ben
toujours en avance sur les modes alors
qu'elle s'en fait encore pipi sait plus
bien moi je sais plus qui je trouve ça
ringard d'eau et bien quelques jours de
la saint-valentin bajul et qu il donc
quoi tu gagnes pas isabelle quand tu
gagnes pas isabelle et puis personne on
nous parle de cette toute dernière
dépense trop qu'est ce qui peut bien
valoir 350 euros 15 à un trauma nikkei a
été très bon et un peu noir puis on
finit tout de suite avec le pg de la
semaine cyril hanouna autorités tendent
et ça peut pas faire tout moment alors
série il ya un chroniqueur cette année
que vous avez complètement métamorphosé
alors pour le deviner
je vais tenter une petite imitation
c'est pas forcément réussi est ce que
vous pensez de l'amour est dans le pré
de serre il attendait de moi quand j'ai
lancé cyril féraud sur le confiance et
je vous le dis c'est est claire aussi
vous êtes un très grand animateur cyril
alors j'adore vous je vous le dis oui
c'est pas encore ça on a on a compris
qu'ils étaient mes phalanges robot c'est
l'animation faite le jour crédit
agricole a perdu quand il sait nicolas
pas né comme vous l'avez complètement
métamorphosé et au début c'est un expert
médias et depuis c'est devenu un char au
regard des jeunes étoiles et comme je
peux vous assurer que certaines
cherchent à roubaix
il était une fois un des hommes de
médias les plus respectés de sa
génération c'est une très grosse
pointure il rigole pas il faisait la
pluie et le beau temps chez france
télévisions que quand vous avez été le
meilleur directeur des divertissements
de france télévisions la télé c'était
son dada la première saison coûté 750
minots jusqu'au jour où les ouvriers
chroniqueuse de thé bmpt paniquer lé
fine et lisse ofi cost géraldine
isabelle non pas elle en fait c'était
surtout de fine art est de faire écouter
par contre tu peux dormir la maison il
ya d'aplats fier champ devant l'échec
il jeta son dévolu sur tiffany en fait
il voulait tout les pécho l'homme que
l'on appelait race rahmane
ensuite tutoyer la dar k
une chose est sûre baba avait créé un
monstre mêmes capillairement le point de
non retour est atteint 2 février dernier
tri
yves rigole alors je vous dirais
technique aulas il est courtois avec
tout le monde sa tribune racb raymond
tiffany pas non non pas du tout non
franchement non juste dans les loges
seront maintenant il est très élégant et
je serai c'est un amour mais s'occupe de
tout le monde bizarre il voudra le toit
c'est un amour et c'est sans doute de la
courtoisie il est très gentil il ya une
distance entre la brague et le fait
d'être très gentil et on leur dit si
d'euros et vous vous tenez sur une radio
toni bou 6 et 8
c'est vrai ça celle ci alors et lui une
voiture fait que keith tiffany alors
j'aime beaucoup tiffany oui est ce que
tu sais comment madaillan la chaleur la
nuit aussi ces deux objets du magnéto
est-ce que ça pour être votre style sa
chair parce qu'ils sont riches bon choix
non mais c'est ce que je lui dis on
dirait un bar mitzvah quoi on dirait
qu'on rit alors et sa bar mitsva à tout
moment donc deviner mais j'ai
l'impression que ça d'achat à 13 ans
quand je le regarde donc moi j'en ai 35
mêlées mais vous rendez compte alors je
vous dis qu on le voit tous nuls on a de
son côté dit la dernière fois l'amour
n'a pas d'âge
tiffany c'est vrai allez vas y veiller
aux intérêts à benjamin benjamin vous
faites ont sûrement la tournée des
médias pour votre livre je vous ai tenté
mais auquel vous raconter la vie de
votre grand mère simone signoret mais
vous faites également la tournée des
chroniqueurs pourquoi pour moi votre
livre bon reflet les ventes
artificiellement une situation le
d'autres cyril quoi regarder un tricheur
benjamin
c'est écrit sur la vous étendez n'est
sûr mais dans son avocat si tu pouvais
en acheter vins mâcon et remboursera en
poussin mais qu'un voire deux tabous
pour faire monter dans les containers et
les ventes de ces déchets une petite
vingtaine à chaque fois je viens juste
on lit votre linge de rencontre entre
chalon et non mais après tu vas pas bien
vivre c'est important pour le monde dans
les mois mais si tu vas la foule et a
fait dire il au moins 10 dans les deux
sens et au remboursement voit que c'est
elle doit aller sur lci au départ
[Musique]
le mec timide les deux sens mal pour un
great ans n'a pas apporté pour plus anti
vendu un grille-pain un téléphone il n'a
pas duré fiat a glissé un peu une clause
légale achetez vous qui vous inquiétez
pas mathématique il passe est déjà si on
en achète un sympa et je voulais à dire
vous l'avez dédicacé oui absolument
voilà une fois tu es mon ami a gardé le
meilleur pour la fin cyril paie quoi
sert il
vous êtes un grand animateur tout le
monde le sait a commenté ray beaucoup de
talent quand tu commences comme ça c'est
pas du tout vous avez la vanne facile
vous avez une répartie exceptionnel et
ça vous ne le faisais pas de nulle part
cette semaine encore on a eu du très
grand cyril alors on connaît la cash
machine lancement ringard voici tout de
suite la casse machine
j'ai envie de prendre ton cul pour une
trousse alors c'est parce que vous avez
ce soir qu'est ce que j'ai dit au sujet
de la clean qu'est ce que j'ai dis
jamais tu lis mais ils me disent on va
l'augmenter tout cas vous risquez pas
d'être augmentée casta caste à la loeb
ce casque à casque à lalobbe st tu sais
effectivement comme l'a dit guillaume ça
n'a absolument pas bougé d'un iota par
rapport aux habituels ou vous appelle
dans deux minutes allez chercher vos
dalmatiens il vous revient dans deux
minutes deux minutes c'est un cap et là
je pense qu'on sera bien marché pour la
merde que c'est
c'est mon premier producteur de télé
mais j'ai jamais rien fait les audiences
a pas particulièrement hier soir oui
barbe à papa et ma bulle
toi tu dois avoir un bagout machine avec
l'oseille que tu le prends depuis 15 ans
sur la vie de ma mère
entre rtl et ici on te paye quand même
même si tu ne manques pas frères toit
sur la tête de ma mère chaude doit dire
à mon europe de deken pourra voir
l'héritage après savait pas d impôt
nouveau c'est sympa que je
[Rires]
l'avoir breton portable aventure dans la
gueule c'est pas